hello hey canada
well first of all you've literally won
every award aren't you sick of this
stuff
oh no
especially when are you nominated hi
canadian hi canadian how are you who is
your biggest critic myself yeah yeah by
far
congratulations you're nominated
thank you so much uh it's been kind of
surprised by the same time not really
i like that right
and keisha had to check in with the host
of the show tay diggs who watched the
red carpet with girlfriend april jones
once you get out there you feel
everybody's support i got the support of
this one right here um
yeah and then you just read the
teleprompter try to relax yeah
do you practice in the mirror are you
talk is he walking around talking to
himself like how is he born to do this
while keisha was on the red carpet with
some of the nice biggest stars halle
berry was inside receiving one of the
evening's biggest honors the see her
award i realized we truly need to see
each other's reality no matter how
uncomfortable it makes us so that we
might stop judging and stop pointing
fingers but rather find compassion and
empathy for the others ted lasso and the
power of the dog both led the knights
winners with four trophies each
and succession took home three awards
including karen culkin's best supporting
actor in a drama series win i was just
telling jeremy how i really hope they
don't say my name i was really looking
forward to that relief of not having to
say anything will smith sure had a busy
weekend as he won best actor at the
critics choice awards and the 2022
baptist for his role in king richard
this is the critic's choice so just so
the critics know this is what i tried to
do every time
other big winners from the bastas
include troy cotzer for supporting actor
ariana dubose for best supporting
actress and lashana lynch was awarded
the rising star i think it's great that
all of you are recognizing my work from
all the way across the sea timmy tolen
our casting director
yes please clap for her
um
[Music]
i would not be here
had she not dragged me in the room
it's true
so before steven said yes someone had to
open the door and it was her wow thank
you barbara broccoli michael wilson
kerry everyone involved in no time to
die
everyone involved in my career my
parents i have very supportive parents
and the power of the dog was also a big
winner taking home best picture with
benedict cumberbatch accepting the award
on behalf of director jane campion yes
so um bafta i'd like
damn it that's my speech oops